all right before we move off of cpac for
the day just a couple other little
highlights from other speakers at cpac
texas 2022 of course mike pillow uh my
pillow ceo mike lindell continues to be
obsessed with machines you guys remember
his obsession with machines we're doing
a class action lawsuit against all
machines he made the principled and
defiant and scary announcement at cpac
that 54 countries have now been taken by
the machines this is very important you
hear me on this over 54 countries have
now been taken by the machines or are
getting taken by the machines yeah and
you never get to go back
venezuela australia they're gone
australia does not use voting machines
by the way don't get to vote out the
machines once they're there once they're
there you don't get your country back so
as you can imagine obviously i now have
that on my sound board as well over 54
countries have now been taken by the
machines yep here's ted cruz uh texas
republican senator ted cruz he now has
this pronoun quip that he uses at every
opportunity and the crowd loves it but
he just sounds so dumb
well my name is ted cruz and my pronouns
are kiss my ass
whoa
that counts as clever and interesting
for the american right here is rick
scott rick scott who's a republican
senator of florida
i challenge you to follow what the hell
rick scott is talking about here this is
bonkers stuff everyone will obey and no
one will be allowed to complain
you do speak up boom you're going to be
cancelled cancelled your views if you
don't conform with big tech
fauci or neil young
you'll be taking off spotify youtube
facebook and twitter yep in fact i
expressed displeasure at two neil young
songs
and we're about to lose our youtube
channel it's crazy out there
the militant left america are the
modern-day version of book burners no
[Applause]
he was expecting more applause on that
one did you see he does this pause and
you can tell
he's expecting more applause and when it
doesn't come he just waits modern-day
version of book burners
yeah
that's right says one guy
canceling silence and banning from the
internet is book burning
these are the most narrow-minded
intolerant people our country has ever
seen
really struggling with the applause
lines and i also didn't realize rick
scott's diction was so poor like i
didn't realize he was this bad of a
speaker
they are completely ignorant of both
world history and american history
socialism leads to two things
poverty and oppression
there's no socialism here i mean
that
that may or may not be true but the u.s
isn't the socialist country biden's not
a socialist democrats are not socialists
social is not a new idea
it's one of the dumbest oldest most
discreet ideas of the 20th century
that resulted in the deaths of 100
million people
if these democrats who have no idea how
the real world works or acting like they
just invented socialism
yeah so just an electric speaker rick
scott impossible to follow and then
lastly here is marjorie taylor greene
again saying christian nationalism is a
great thing but when i said that i'm a
christian nationalist i have nothing to
be ashamed of because that's what most
americans are we're proud of our faith
very untrue many americans are nominally
christian
but christian nationalism meaning this
inextricable
intertwined nature of christianity and
government
most americans are not for that marjorie
taylor green is just flat out wrong so
an absurd absurd cpac texas 2022 will
take a quick break and be back after
this with the results of the alex jones
trial